hi my name is Simon and I'm going into
my third year eating for a master's
degree in physics from some Peter's
College Oxford I've been running this
YouTube channel now for about a year
answering people's questions about
applications to Oxford and Cambridge
interview questions stuff like that this
video is a compilation video frequently
asked questions I've done one of these
before and you can find that here but
before I go into the actual questions
people have been asking me I'm going to
give one piece of ice that I'm going to
refer back to throughout this entire
video and that is check the department
website and the university website it
seems like most of the people that
contact me you haven't done that and
pretty much all their questions can be
answered by just having a quick look
through particularly the department
website that the university website is
also really useful by far and away the
most commonly asked question that I had
was I've got these results I do this in
my spare time I predicted to get this
this this am I good enough to get in
while I get an interview and everybody's
different
every case is different and there's no
easy answer to this kind of question
when people ask me this I've been using
a couple of simple criteria one at GCSE
do you have four or five eight stars and
less than one or two B's - I predicted
to get all A's at a level maybe with an
a-star if you're doing four or five
subjects and if you get one be predicted
not a big deal three are you doing the
relevant a levels for university subject
best way to check that is check the
website this is actually really commonly
asked questions so I'm going to link to
that particular webpage down below now
remember that these criteria are really
rough rules if you adjust on the outline
of one of those then it's not something
to really stress about the important
ones are the a levels because
universities base their offers on a
levels GCSEs will be looked up but not
as much no nowhere near as much as
a-levels you need to be realistically
getting all A's with an a star like I
say if you get predicted a B in one of
your subjects provided that you're doing
four or five a-levels it's not such a
big deal because offers are made on only
three a-levels that said it will still
count against you but nowhere near as
much as most people seem to think
remember you don't have to be a demigod
in order to get an interview awful or
dare I say a place people like me get in
I'm completely normal
apart from making YouTube videos when
you get to Oxford or Cambridge you
realize that the people there aren't
different they are just normal people
they're exactly like you I mean yeah
they're more intelligent than average
they've got better results than average
sure but they're not a set apart they're
not that different any reason they got
in is because they did well on their
exams not saying that anyone can be I
managed again and I went to a state
school I did all right
I wasn't best in my year at a levels I I
did well in my exams and I did a couple
of things on the side and I got in
because I'm a physicist I had a lot of
people asking me one question about
physics which I'm gonna cover really
briefly which was that do I need further
maths in order to do physics degree you
don't need a hundred percent to do it
but you need it maybe 95 percent it's
not a listed requirement on the website
doesn't say you have to have it but you
are a much weaker applicant if you don't
have it and you'll be a disadvantage in
first year lots of people get in who
haven't done further maths but they are
at a disadvantage that said pretty much
all the first term is spent getting
people who haven't done further maths up
to speed so you're doing an a-level in
eight weeks which is pretty tough going
if your school doesn't offer further
maths and you might want to look into
the further maths Network which I'll put
a link to down below if you can do
further maths I really recommend you do
and I'd really really recommend that you
do the mechanics modules I've had quite
a lot of contact from international
students who have asked one question in
particular which is just Oxford or
Cambridge recognise my qualifications
from the USA Malaysia whatever what do I
need in those qualifications to get in
answer check the website I'll put a link
to this one down below because it is
really frequently asked I can't go for
all of them here so just check the web
also international students have been
asking do I have to come to Oxford or
Cambridge for my interview answer is
kind of yes but not really really really
should try and come like it's not just
important for the interview to give an
impression of yourself but it's also
important just to see the city and make
sure that you are going to be
comfortable
now if you absolutely can't make it then
there are schemes to do interviews via
Skype or down the phone I'll put it into
that down below as well one question I
got asked a lot was what did I get in my
exam results I don't really feel too
comfortable talking about it at length
so I'm just going to flash them up on
the screen now you can pause if you're
interested
so that's what I got one thing that came
up surprisingly commonly was people
asking is Cambridge better than Oxford
or vice-versa it's it's an impossible
question to answer not least because I'm
clearly biased but because it's
impossible to compare them they're just
different on a subject to subject basis
you can have ranking tables that will
tell you that one University will have
better research than the other that one
might have more famous professors than
the other but the courses will vary
massively from subject to subject
objective comparison of the two it
doesn't really have any meaning to take
me as an example I went to Oxford
because I wanted to do a physics degree
whereas a Cambridge I'd have to do a
Natural Sciences degree where I pick and
choose from all the different Sciences I
knew that I only wanted to do physics so
I went to Oxford
even though Cambridge has the better
department Oxford has the better physics
degree there it's a personal choice no
one is better than the other one might
see some people more than the other
Cambridge is a market talented and it
definitely has a quieter filter whereas
Oxford is a city it's much bigger and it
feels like there's much more going on
all at once that might suit some people
it might not it's a putt it's a personal
choice lastly I had a fair few emails
from people saying I've got perfect and
everything I've got a B and one more
choice this is going to mean I can't get
in No
you've got to look at this from a
different perspective it's so easy when
you're gunning for something like
entrance to really prestigious
university to just look at it from your
perspective and you get really caught up
in it but you have to keep things in
perspective one be in one module in one
subject isn't going to change
diddly-squat sure if you're doing three
a levels one of them's history and you
get a B maybe a C in one of the modules
and you want to do history Oxford maybe
that does count for a bit more but as
long as it's not in the subject that
you're really gunning for like for me
physics then it's not really going to
count for much at all don't panic much
better than just obsessing over what's
happened in the past is to keep moving
forwards and make sure that you're
trying as hard as possible to get
in everything if you keep looking back
you're never going to move forwards and
I think that's about it if there's a
question that isn't covered in this
video or any of the other ones on this
channel please feel free to either leave
a comment on here or a comment on my
channel or message me I will try my hose
to get back to every single person it
may take a little while during term time
because well I let them build up by that
five or six build up and win box and
then replace them all in an evening so
if I don't reply to you in a couple of
days it's not it's not what I don't care
it's just I've been a bit busy so good
luck to anyone who's applying good luck
if you've got an entity and I hope
they'll have a bit more content to
upload on this channel quite seen so
thanks